hi how's it going my name is markiplier
and welcome to 2019 the last of it
anyway we've only got a few days left
until 2019 is over and yes I survived it
contrary to popular belief from the past
few days since I haven't been uploading
since I've been home for Christmas
vacation I have survived 2019 it almost
came for me at the end there but I am
alive how are you doing welcome
everybody thank you so much for being
here and thank you so much for joining
me on this adventure 2019 was a girthy
year very thick probably like six or
seven theses on the thickness of that
year
lots of stuff happened so we're gonna go
through it whereas last year I did it a
year in the review and I was like oh a
lot of [ __ ] happened but I didn't
actually show all the [ __ ] that happened
and don't get me wrong 29 it 2018 was a
fairly girthy year but 2019 was the cur
theist year I've ever experienced
practically couldn't take it
it was so girthy yes hello I'm here and
you are here with me and and if
everyone's who's here with me is a
beautiful person and I appreciate you
guys for joining me on this adventure
before we go into 2020 though we need to
look back at 2019 and see where it all
went so horribly wrong and oh you could
point to this and that and here and
there as to where it went wrong but
we're gonna go through each one
individually and we're gonna look at
everything and we're gonna see exactly
what went wrong but first thanks so much
for your patience and understanding for
me or sorry not patience and
understanding
screaming ranting raving cursing
shouting to the heavens where the hell
is markiplier I was home for Christmas
and I was enjoying a nice break because
holy hell the past few months have been
tough been working on a lot of stuff
been working on love things yadda yadda
basic excuses same thing I say every
year but I was home relaxing there's
very nice spend some time with some
family and oh yeah yeah every everyone
who's in this chat is now much more
girthy for just being here everyone who
is a part of this stream has gone +2 in
girth Ness so congratulations if you
were looking to get thicker all you need
to do stay in this live stream every
minute is another point added on to your
thickness so just stick around
sit back relax let the girth overtake
you yeah congratulations everybody all
your uh all your New Year's wishes are
coming true you if you were at a New
Year's resolution to be thicker this
year boy howdy you are going to oh yeah
yeah oh yeah I got even got me a remote
for these lights finally I haven't had
had ii-i've been meaning to you this is
like a I don't want to cheapen the gift
I really appreciate it thank you even
for getting me this but I can actually
control it with the remote now which is
awfully nice Oh God
what the hell is that that was disco
also known as seizure mode okay whatever
rainbow there's rainbows pestle pestle
well that's cool that's neat garden just
kind of garden is that nice yeah let's
do fire I like it it's like a warm fire
so yes thank you all so much for being
here
Oh what is what the hell did I just see
in chat I have no idea is that one of
the the super chat emote things thank
you so much but don't waste your money
on me I literally might not even thank
you for it I might insult you so if you
give me super chat anything it's gonna
be like 50/50 shot of whether it's gonna
be an insult or a thank you so just
hedge your bets on that one oh don't
worry don't worry I'm making everybody
thick in here yes the thickening is upon
us 2020 shall be the thickest year that
we have ever experienced oh yes it is
true but I do want to say thank you
everybody so much for your patience and
understanding truly it is good to get a
break I love working I really do and
even when I was at home I was just
sitting around being like
what do I do now what do i do what do i
do I can't I can't sit back and relax
and it'll be it'll be too much for me
but I didn't want to thank you everybody
so for your patience it's been a few
days since the last video I know I'm so
sorry a few days but do dishonest has
been trucking through every day that was
pretty much all the work that we were
doing is just getting videos ready for
that but that's not why we're here what
we're here to talk about focus everybody
stop talking about the thickness stop
appreciating your new thickness and look
at me look at me in the eyes look at me
in the eyes you're not looking
look there you go all right cool listen
we're gonna review 2019 we're gonna see
all of the video we're not gonna watch
all the videos but we're gonna see all
the videos that I made throughout this
past year and we're gonna highlight some
of the landmark ones there were big
moments in the channel because we had a
lot of big moments in this channel in
2019 so we're gonna highlight some of
those we're gonna look over some of the
things that were kind of overlooked
maybe and I'm gonna give a general sense
of whether I should be prouder this year
or not and starting off with it I think
that I can be relatively confused to
whether or not I'm gonna be proud of
this or not but this avert your eyes is
my channel everybody I'm so sorry you
have to see this in the state that it is
this I think this is the first video
that I uploaded of the new year is this
true oh yeah that's right ma da with my
mom because this one was before the new
year yeah December 31st ignore that
rabid man there that's not what that's
about
oh look I'm live hey I'm live guys guys
that's so cool that's awesome live Hey
look there you are hey it's you guys
ah that's awesome some life hey look
cool hey it's you guys look if the the
the thing the thing with the dancing
thing whatever the pair thing is it was
there yeah that thing you can see it is
it's just like a perpetual scrolling
thing with the dancing thing whatever
the pair thing is it was there yeah that
thing yeah that thing see it's like yeah
that yeah that thing alright anyway we
got to get out of this before things get
too deep oh also hey look it's that cool
feature of the to thank the members of
this channel thing but they that thing
the thing that thinks the think thinks
the members that's pretty cool anyway
whatever get out there that's not what
I'm here for
go away that's not what we're all about
but it's cool that I'm live here if you
III didn't know that it showed that if
you were looking at my channel but this
is the first video that I put up of this
year a good video my mom played five
nights at Freddy's 3 I think this is the
first occasion where she actually got
through a couple of the nights because
oh hell yeah sweet add in come and give
me that ad revenue wow yeah what do we
got
oh the league of legends [ __ ] hi hi
alright so this is the first video that
I put out of this year it's not exactly
a monumental video it's not like a like
a incredibly amazing intricate video but
it's a good video you know it's got my
mom in there and we're in my mom's house
my old recording room when I live with
my mom when I started so you know what
that's a pretty good place to start
it's not that bad it's pretty good I
can't complain about that but not that
monumental in the grand scheme of things
that was the first one then I did
another with my mom denna three scary
games number 15 and then
the grand return this this is actually
interesting because mark Blair makes
creme brulee it had been a while it had
been a while since the last market Blair
makes this one was great just because it
brought back the threat of fire yeah
oddly enough fires hot if you didn't
know that fire is very warm it's real
it's real tough Hey look I'm live a
fires hot fires hot fires crazy harm
yeah Hey look I'm live yes so I when we
when we did creme brulee it was like the
first time back look I'm live that we
were doing it we came back and do it
like a speech jammer we were we we were
I think just because I'm live right now
live I should turn this off okay so we
did creme brulee and I was really nice
because back into markable are makes and
that was fun and also just like
completely chaotic and what it was was
what it is but that is pretty early on
in this year and it brought back a few
of those which is cool Denton Resident
Evil 2 I forgot about Resident Evil 2
was this year that's right it came out
just like this year such a good game and
then they announced resident evil 3 and
that's gonna be such fun yeah I'm gonna
play that one I never played Resident
Evil 2 and to experience like the
remaster and have such a good remaster
that was just a nice experience all the
way through like Resident Evil after
after Resident Evil 7 came out there
they've been killing it they've been
killing it because they know the recipe
in their remakes
as much as I'm like I harp on remix in
movies I'm all about this remake because
it was just it was so well done who's
practically a new game just because the
remake was so well when you remake it
like a movie or something it's not it's
a still a movie you know it's still
pretty much the same experience
you know they rarely enhance anything
but you know that was pretty cool oh yes
sorry playing board games with Bob and
Wade the eye tracker
I forgot of I think this is age
restricted I'm almost positive if I
click on this is this age restricted I
got no it's not age restricted that's
odd this one should be age I mean not
for any other reason than just like I'd
be just well I mean I think is it not
I'm not logged in right now so it must
not be addressed
I won't even play well I won't even load
it oh I see how it is I see how it is
there it is there it is so much was it
be that this one did I edit this one
maybe it's look I think it was me I did
so much censoring of this goddamn video
and the maybe the threatening minion
somehow drew my eye almost every single
time not a monumental video in this year
but definitely an interesting one if you
haven't seen that one yet hey I got that
eye tracker thing and I just tried to
see where I eyes would go and it turns
out it was minion and penis and then
rock that looks like a penis in that
order of priority for where they were
gonna go so that was that subnautica
below zero came back oh no what of her
pants Oh pants is a cloak promo pretzels
Settlers of Catan apex Legends camp Oh
apex legends came out in 2019 didn't it
beginning of this year was that this
year was that this year that it got was
that this year that apex legs just came
out I don't really care I I don't I
don't like the game very much so it
doesn't really matter to me but I'm like
was that this year I don't remember
those those here Yes No maybe so who
cares
battle Royales who gives an ass alright
anyway back to it uh horseback riding I
rode a horse this year
I forgot I rode a horse guys I was on a
horse
that's and Oh stay do that then I would
think oh my god
double ads oh but the sweet ad revenue
oh yeah but it's good there I am riding
a horse look at me on a horse there's
really nothing else about this video
that just like I was on a horse it was
it was an interesting experience is this
lady I forget her name but she would not
believe that I had never ridden a horse
before which I think I should take as a
compliment
doli I should I hate to say only a
million views it's been out for almost a
year now it's only got 1.07 wait this is
great why does this one get one and then
and then toe toe be eye tracker gets Val
well because they're boobs in that one
but ah man ah come on can't believe it
I'm insulted I'm insulted
big important announcement you just
gotta know about it is probably some
stoop hello everybody my name is
markiplier and tomorrow we're going to
be doing a charity livestream to rate I
knew it it's a charity livestream sorry
I'm just so funny is the thing I'm
hilarious I look at myself and I can't
help but laugh I'm just so goddamn funny
anyway so yeah it's a charity lecture
enough but very very important wait was
that oh my god that was further - what
that was for the what was gonna be the
48 hour livestream I forgot about that
oh my god the 40 the 24 hour livestream
was then right after this I would have
completely forgotten about that I was
gonna do a 48 hour livestream to raise
half a million dollars hang on let me
just enhance this I was gonna I was I
was gonna do a a 48 hour livestream to
raise half a million dollars we did it
in 24 hours which was stunning ah and I
couldn't believe it
dad that was the thing like I was just
prepared to like slog it through I was
it I just wanted to do do a livestream
that was just gonna be like hey we're
gonna we're gonna go and whatever
happened
happens if we get to it we get to it if
we don't we don't but I'm gonna go for
48 hours straight and then we got it in
24 $500,000 that you guys raise for
charity in 24 hours which is
unprecedented in in my experience in
doing charity livestreams by myself
so yeah that was this year I almost
completely forgot about that can't
believe that I can't believe I forgot
they're like this is it this is why I'm
doing a livestream to go through every
single thing individually because if if
I don't do it individually I will forget
because I've been so busy that kind of
things it's like swing by so when is
this what's the timeline here this is
February 22nd February 22nd more people
watch this announcement than me riding a
horse can't believe this I can't believe
yeah.but down yeah no that's that's the
thing hey why isn't saying I'm live here
hey what the hell hey what the hell
YouTube hey you two what the hell what
the hell is going on here okay February
22nd that's fascinating okay then I
wrote a horse interesting series of
unfortunate drownings through some games
what else happened in this time period
what else was going on at this moment
because if that was a charity livestream
then pretty soon after that I got my
wisdom teeth take it out
there's also this nightmare this is
taking around hello
your friend markiplier
mark is streaming over at I YouTube /
you I'll let apart okay I be hell I
we will be playing be looking at 2019 in
all the videos they're in alright
whatever I'm over this bit alright okay
moving on that's not that's not at all
important but I got my wisdom teeth
taken out I forgot about this people
were demanding that I document the
process behind my well skate I also want
to say I am so proud of my youtuber
instincts like my my youtuber instincts
are so strong here's the thing if you
haven't seen this video go watch it it's
a goddamn delight but also I don't
remember filming half of it because I
was loopy after the surgery so I got to
my wisdom teeth taken out there were
four four of them all sideways had to
come out way too late I should have
gotten taken out years ago I didn't so I
filmed the process because Ethan filmed
his process and it was a wholesome video
so Amy wanted me to film this one so I
asked her and I'll film it but I'm so
proud listen guys you don't understand
I'm so proud of my youtube instincts cuz
this is pure instinct I went ultra
instinct on coming out of surgery and
the first thing I do when I come out of
surgery is I grab my phone and I hit
record and I cannot believe I don't
remember a thing about this I was
totally just completely blank in my mind
I don't remember a thing I will tell you
when I start remembering things in this
video but I grabbed my phone and somehow
open the camera and start recording
[Music]
don't remember saying a thing there
there's actually there's actually like
another three minutes that was cut out
of there but it's all incoherent garbage
of me just like blabbering on to nothing
there's there's there's more footage
there at maybe I could pull it up with
my phone I don't know just to prove a
point
but yeah so I still don't remember I
have not gotten to the point where I
actually remember anything so don't
worry about but yeah if you haven't seen
that video like definitely go see though
and that was a fun one
not because I remember anything about it
but because it was inherently fun and
where's the Stan video I have no idea
maybe I don't have it I might not have
it I might not oh I have it
there okay wait wait wait okay so I
don't know how best to show this but
okay so here all right so holdin this
it's see it's just beeped why is there
no sound that uh there we go
I don't even remember pulling my phone
out but I did and then I started
recording and then I gave up or
something it's just this angle for a
long time
try not to talk as much is what she said
to me and what do i do I just start
blabbing to my oh yeah wait wait there's
more to the handsome man but wait wait
wait okay I started thanking him I
really appreciate what you've done for
me hey wait just
blabbers on like that for a while but
yeah let me continue this
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah that goes on like that for a while
if you haven't seen this video there's
my wisdom tooth removal it is called I
got my wisdom teeth removed I you know
as far as like effort I mean what do you
think about getting your wisdom teeth
taken out is not an easy thing to go
through but as far as effort goes like
not too high but god I love this video
I know Amy loves this video hey I'm live
look at that and just like for some
reason we quote it to each other so it's
because because of this this one quote
here oh wait we're
[Music]
I start to remember I start to remember
right about here this is what I start to
remember I can actually I gosh about
this for a while all the freaking time
and then this we all these jokes all the
time like Tommy is oh good still to this
day it's been like what what day was
this what day was this is March 15th
it's been like nine months since this
came out oh I love this video this is
definitely a highlight a highlight of
2019 for me and it whatever okay so if
you haven't check that one out go check
out I got
beef removed it's a good one it's a good
one oh wait did I miss
no I haven't mister yet okay that's
right uh okay from here I love this song
I love
[Music]
dopamine is rushing through my little
brain
[Music]
okay big shout-out to schmoyoho accent
on the yellow schmoyoho are just amazing
they're amazing they made this song and
a high score in a high school markiplier
they've been just like super cool the
whole group Andrew Michael Evan just
like thank you so much for just helping
out with like these songs and stuff like
this because a lot of these things are
just such cool pieces of like my channel
and I didn't even make them I said the
words but they transformed it into like
a a an awesome song so if you haven't
heard this one I'm back baby it's just
really cool hey I'm live look at that
what recommended videos are coming up
here sort the court I wish they made a
full version on that game that's a good
one interesting interesting that video
this video is hilarious but just because
this is like a compilation of markable
are makes moments and it's really funny
yeah a really funny one Oh aerial silks
God when I realized I was just super
inflexible just like incredibly like the
opposite of athletic I'm slightly better
now but flexibility is no longer my
strong suit when I was a child I was
very flexible when I became a thick ass
adult flexibility went out the window I
had I've got nothing left I haven't even
tried it no flexibility flexibility was
my strong suit once no longer anymore
[Music]
and then the disc we said people give
the [ __ ] out I forgot that was that
moment there yeah that was great
it was not great it actually wasn't
great she was being very nice I can't
remember her name
because I could never Ram her names that
couldn't remember the doctor's name and
my video there so it couldn't remember
this one anyway a good one if you guys
haven't checked that one out definitely
give that a try
egg drop what a video what a marvel are
makes video but yeah
moving on can't can't stop by everything
here my April Fool's joke fencing which
I want to go back and do that was fun oh
yeah a lot of people are big about this
Stan the water man Stan the waters hi
Stan it's me Stan the water man I'm here
hi how are you doing just a three and a
half hour video which is just God Lexi
and edited it that's edited from like a
stream I did I handed it off to Alex I
was like man just like I don't know cut
it up or something I think I want to put
this up there God people loved Stan and
I didn't get why but yeah it's fun to
play
I couldn't keep going streaming stay in
the water man stuff just because I
didn't have time because immediately
after I started doing this even a little
bit what happened was heisst with
markiplier filming started like the
following month I had to go do
pre-production and I could not stream
period nothing I couldn't do anything
because they just absolutely did not
have the time for it there was no way
that was gonna be able to do streams
especially when they take six hours to
do when I don't even have two hours to
like work on normal videos so like
that's about the window of time that I
had so couldn't do that but Stan the
water man oh you you you're beautiful
beautiful beautiful man well I wonder if
I think it's this one actually yeah I'm
Stan Stan the water man here to bring
water to the city of Los Santos all
these great good people here need
my water and I'm here to give it to him
Stan the water man has a purpose in life
and that purpose is to bring water to
the great people of this city as the Sun
sets so does the thirst rise time to be
off let's see if Stan's wise enough to
have locked his bike don't know if
that's locker unlock all right way so
yeah that it's just it's just a bunch of
crap like that and it was fun times I
really did like it I liked GRP was
really fun I didn't get to get into it
too much but you know he's like it was
like the fun of improv with like whoever
the hell decided to come up and say hi
to you which was really cool uh there
was something else I was gonna say in
regards to that but I've completely
forgotten what it was and so therefore
it probably wasn't that important and
you know remembering things has just
overrated anyway so why even bother with
that anyway I what the hell was it was
something that was happening in this
time period but now I can't remember so
who even cares anymore cuz I don't
apparently alright whatever back to it
everybody shut up everybody shut up it's
fine Damien Damien what a beauty what a
delight what a treat that can't be beat
Damien Damien
came out I May 12th okay we've we've
jumped April gone
forget about April April doesn't exist
anymore a prefer get about April gone
no no one even acknowledge that April
exists Damian I am so unbelievably happy
with how it turned out I'm so proud of
occupier games who did the animation
behind it I ain't just like I love this
it was so fun and also it was very
stressful to work on I worked on this
while I was doing pre-production for a
heist with markiplier I I only did the
sound design I mean I wrote it and
whatnot and directed it and what
whatever but I was doing the sound
design that was like the majority of my
work cuz I did most of the voice acting
besides Pam who was Celine but this is
just oh well I still look back at him
I'm so happy this existed I'm so happy
this was a thing so happy can I pause
real quick I have I have a natural
distrust of honey I don't know what it
is
I don't know why but I naturally
distrust honey and I don't okay all
right guys we're gonna everyone listen I
don't know what it is but my gut tells
me that nothing in life is free so
where's all these savings coming from
and like the money that people get from
honey I don't trust it they push so much
advertising they push so much
advertising on YouTube they do brand
deals with other youtubers I think
they've even offered me and I said no
cuz I just don't trust honey there's
some there's I have a feeling there's
gonna in like a couple years there's
gonna be the great honey conspiracy oh
like 20 22 and I don't know what is I
have no I'm sure it's fine and like I
got no problem with like the concept of
an app that like clips coupon codes for
you that's great that
sounds great on its surface but there's
some shady [ __ ] going on I can't put my
finger upon it but why do they they say
spend millions on advertising and then
people are getting money out of it and
that people are are saving money out of
it and that makes sense but the other
part doesn't make sense and then
something's going on here who where's
all this money coming from where is
honey getting the money where's Ari
getting there moe where's Holly getting
all their money from they should be
losing money in the grand scheme of
everything being compared across the
internet shouldn't they be losing an
incredible amount of money considering
how much they're saving other people and
giving to people something's going on
there
I don't trust honey I don't know what it
is I have no evidence to back it up
everyone that I tell this thinks and I'm
crazy and they're like Oh honey's great
I use honey all the time I'm like what
the [ __ ] is going on and a honey HQ what
is happening where's all this money
coming from cuz nothing like they
everywhere you look
advertising's for honey youtubers across
the board promos for honey where's that
money coming from
how are they paying for all these people
have they paying for all those that Sam
Sann
there's millions the millions in
advertising where's it all coming from I
don't know what's their business plan
doesn't sit right with me does it right
I have no I have nothing I have nothing
other to say besides that but am i M am
I the only one that just has an inherent
distrust I don't know I don't get it do
you guys like I haven't I have no idea
I see maja [ __ ] now it's like this has
been itching away with me for so long
I've had this like deep-seated doubt
about honey and it's just like I don't
trust it I just don't trust it I don't
trust it there's something about it I
just don't trust it so don't use it so
don't trust it it's the same thing like
with like the the DNA test things look
I'm not gonna give you my DNA it's my
DNA you can edit FBI if I listen listen
if I disappear if I disappear like in
the next few
it was honey if I disappear in the
future and then suddenly like marklar
just mysteriously disappears it was
honey
cuz there's some shady [ __ ] happening I
don't trust it I don't trust it
okay so I'm not the only one but I am it
seems like I am in the minority here
which is fair I get that I get anyway so
back to the point at hand which is
Damien which I love
[Music]
what what a beauty of a goddamn video I
love this one uh it is easily one of the
the one of the videos that I'm
absolutely most proud of that I've ever
made it's not perfect I know that none
of the videos that I've ever made it
perfect but like this one I'm just so
proud of as like a learning experience
as like a creative endeavor as something
that I could just try and see if it
worked like the the previous one that
like matched that quality was trying to
do who killed
markiplier which is just an incredible
task like trying to do but Damien I love
love love love Damien I'm so happy with
it I'm so happy with how it turned out
I'm so happy with the response to it I
just I loved it if you haven't seen
Damien yet like go see Damien because
it's such a fascinating look into like
the discrepancy of the type of content I
make on YouTube because I make some
wildly different things on YouTube I am
aware of this like my my channel which
is inherently a gaming focused channel
I've also put out like some pretty high
production quality stuff because I like
to do this kind of stuff and I don't see
really the point of separating it out to
like a different channel because like
this is my channel this is Mark Blair
this is who I am
and I want to showcase what I can do and
god I just I really love it and I don't
like it I just I really happy with how
it turned out it's a good one May 12th
is when that came out and I was in the
thick of pre-production in Austin I
didn't even think I was gonna get it up
like I wanted to get it out before we
got too indepe I was pulling like
all-nighters just trying to get done and
it came out beautifully and I didn't do
half the work that the artist did oh my
god I didn't do have to work anyway
great great alright love that one very
good
oh yeah and then ball these basics had
their one-year-anniversary that's that's
interesting I don't think the full game
has come out yet but it exists and it is
their tie-dye
nail art best and marklar makes best of
three series games oh yeah five nights
at freddy's help-wanted this let me tell
you saw
tell you something this saved my this
and don't escape dona don't escape and
five guys everybody's help wanted saved
my ass when it came to making videos in
austin because it was like i did i
didn't do our long videos i was
uploading just one of these every once
in a while like one a day they were
there i could come back this is what I
was doing in May 25th I was spending
every day in pre-production we just
started filming I think like the end of
May so we might have started filming at
this point here actually we definitely
were filming at this point here like 8
a.m. to 8 p.m. days I would get home I
would have to eat make get a video done
for for the next day and then go to bed
and get enough sleep so I get up at 6
a.m. go to the location so we can start
filming again and then start working
this game saved my ass because it was
like all I did was record for 30 minutes
and then I did the dirtiest quickest
chopping of cutting I could possibly do
and then I shot it up on YouTube and it
was just content I have there are times
in my life on YouTube where I have just
made content for the sake of content and
no other purpose or higher calling than
that it is just pure content to throw up
there just so that there's not nothing
this is an example of that and guys
thank you five Rises Thank You Scott
Cawthon for putting this out or the
company that made it actually just like
oh man the sweet delicious juicy content
the content the content ah
YouTube's youtubers thrive on content
that's our in our veins is not blood it
is content and we shoot it out into the
Internet in copious amounts as much as
we can but when we're running dry and
we're being I was already being drained
of all my content for heists with
Margalo getting sucked out of me left
and right
they were sucking the thickness from me
and that goes ah no my content oh god
what is that shining light could it be
it is
five nights at from B's VR the VR was a
pain in the ass at it but it was only
just like getting it in the right place
but I got so you know us youtubers we
get milked for our sweet delicious
savory content on a daily basis and
that's why I am as thick as I am because
I'm swollen with my content and everyone
wants a piece of it so you know but it's
okay cuz I got more than enough to share
around this isn't a sexual thing at all
I'm talking about content I have seen
girl here right now
there we go yeah so uh thank you five
nights at Freddy's Help Wanted for
getting me through this period May 25th
thank you so much so from from this
point on to about oh my god there well
there was a best-of which is let me tell
you content that is straight-up just
content because that was me lick see and
also was a hero during this point in
time I want to point that out let me let
me emphasize that lick see in he's he's
an amazing editor and he helps me out
with this like horrible amalgamation of
chaos that I call it channel and he does
an amazing work on it and he's even
helping out with newness honest he's an
incredible editor and he's an even
better animator and he's probably an
even better person like he was helping
me out by like crafting content he was
conjuring it out of the air like a
magician he was pulling content from the
ether like grabbing it from out from the
sky and pulling it into the existence
with best of compilation and he made
this masterpiece of couple of a -
markiplier I'm here joined by ether for
tonight your dead going
now when I was a child I couldn't afford
to do a race we couldn't even afford
eggs we have a chicken but then we had
to kill for an entertainment I've never
taught anything in my life really never
know I grew up poor like we couldn't
even afford shirts let alone color so
we're gonna be doing something nice
something really like fun it's more of a
craft thing it's smoke some grass you
call him a Sherman was it me
pause piss SS make a shock mount penis
like me to put yours on slave you guys
have some sort of gift or cliffs that
makes it super sexual I'm sure I know
this is just be laughing at videos that
I've made but honest to god like I
sometimes forget that I've actually made
funny [ __ ] in my time money too like
like there's actually been funny cut
there there is funny content on my
channel and sometimes I forget that just
like easy
[ __ ] baby so goddamn funny you want
to live fast fall he passes wheels
microwave I'm just laughing it even
being an idiot that's all that's all
that really
[Laughter]
what's funny is like I'm laughing now
and the same exact laugh is being echoed
back in the video because I it's just
[Music]
[Laughter]
guys you're not listening stop mixing
just drive where is this what what is
this well it says that what we talk to
he pass like that you're right get so
many bits of paper but here's something
that others don't know we're gonna make
these shirts but we're not gonna do it
with our eyes we're gonna do it with our
souls like making love you don't do with
your eyes you don't do it your body do
with your heart
you get a large soul thank you no time
someone knows there's multiple colors in
this one sorry burgeoning one who
virgins in the field one who likes to
burgeon themselves so glad I paid for
all your improv lessons oh you don't
have a feeling in your pie you don't
have it we're dying do it again oh you
do I got this because I just like I just
really enjoyed this video I do that I do
that for very few videos but this one is
just like what I could I wash it I
thoroughly enjoy like this is the
definition of recycling content I know
but but but is what this is about
looking back looking back anyway kindly
[Laughter]
this is another example of a joke it
follows my life but not because anyone
else is saying it but because I
constantly bring it up but I only bring
it up because of how uncomfortable I
don't know one finds it funny but me but
I find it very funny
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's time to Avenger brother Barry no
you have to start over right and I know
you're you're at the advantage you're
gone ambidextrous no mixing anything no
it isn't it is distinctly different I'll
get out of it being the same thing say I
why it's not all post me the only person
who has the right to vote in this all
right well the only person with the
right to vote didn't vote correctly they
said me instead of nay the motion has
passed democracy in action
just because your democracy is a failure
as a government oh that's another tough
[Laughter]
show me bottoms here Hot Fuzz it's hot
fun so soggy bottoms here soggy bottoms
here okay let's finish maybe this tastes
really good
I don't think the the random outbursts
of like what's the word there's a fancy
word for it but just indignant rage just
like hey stop rubbing cut it down get
some help
thank you everybody so much for watching
this has been another markiplier makes
they're slowly getting out of my control
I won't be able to contain the beasts
for much longer run while you still have
life oh yeah I scared it over but
there's another one oh yeah of classroom
oh we can't watch another there's it
there's two there's this only 99 IQ
individuals may watch is the name of
this one only 99 a queue if an
individual may want and yes that's a lot
more clickable than best of markiplier
makes but I think this one is also just
as funny because it's it's literally
because markiplier makes itself is funny
therefore it's just highlights from it
so
say what you will take your pick there's
two these are technically I have no
consistency of naming conventions on on
my channel at all I'll do whatever
whatever whimsy takes me and there's
absolutely nothing I can do to get
consistent about it because sometimes
I'll be like I'll just call it exactly
what it is and there will be nothing
else to it like best of marco bar makes
or i'll name it something stupid just
because i the only reason the only
reason this is called this is because of
this picture cuz i was like as picture
fits with this title better and that's
literally only reason and i didn't even
try this thumbnail died like the
ideological person in in the extreme
okay anyway now we are officially
getting to the point where i am back
home oh my god back home finally this
would be about the point when ice with
markiplier finished oh yeah i i don't
really take time to read super chat
donations because why are you giving me
super chad donut i'm markiplier don't
why i don't appreciate it
i guess but at the same time there are
also plenty of other people that you
could be giving super tattoo than me if
you want to throw your money at me look
my pockets are open but there is really
no need for it so dude do what you will
like I said I'll probably insult you if
you give me money so whatever that's
pretty much the point now if you become
a member
gosh you're a hero you're you're a god
and or goddess amongst mere mortal
people members are just so beautiful
every one of them is a unique snowflake
if you want to get a multiplier on your
thickness bonus just from watching this
stream if you remember you get like a
five times bonus rate five times
it's incredible what members get the
value is outstanding incredible even
unbelievable and what they do for me is
unforgivable
it can't be forgiven because it doesn't
need to be forgiven because it's it's
it's appreciated
therefore it's unforgivable in the right
context
there you go that's good
all right whatever I've done my plugs
that I need to get out of the way all
right
so blink we where are we where we I had
my likeness stolen from me god this
video this is in the world I'm just
getting back into the swing of things
I'm finally back home I can get like
more variety out I can do different
things here and there I can try the
Super Mario maker stuff came out I can
just like explore where I'm going with
it Yatta Yatta pocus stock we played a
bit of that that was fun except it
wasn't very stressful but the big Mamba
the big mama Jamba the the pillar that
kept my channel afloat in the darkness
that brought me out from Austin from
filming got me back into being a
youtuber which is what it's all about
Sour Patch Kid I love you ah he's like
this they're just like free to play you
can jump in with your buddies have some
fun
Kabam okay sour patch kids I made this
on a whim I made it on a whim I made it
on a complete whim because I couldn't
believe that there was a sour patch kids
cereal I thought that it wouldn't taste
good I had no idea how it's gonna be but
I was like heck I'll give it a try see
what it is I cannot believe how many
people wanted to see this goddamn video
this is watch 3.2 million times
why and the follow-up the follow-up of
the does this is sour patch kids ice
cream which means that they put sour
patch kids in an ice cream or they made
ice cream with sour patch kids which is
a different idea than cereal but don't
pay attention to that right now it's
it's not important what is important is
this this is my tactical shovel
I bought this off of Amazon the same
place I got the material from weird
website you can buy all these things and
it seems to know exactly what you want
whenever you don't even think they want
it anyway anyway so this brought about
the birth of the tactical shovel the
beautiful amazing tactical shovel I
still have it I haven't really used it
for digging wink no I haven't really yet
but yeah so I still have it I plan to
use it at some point for a video but I
haven't gotten around to it yet cuz got
busy we are now in August
we're time jumping all over the place
look guys time is times real funny on
this chair time kind of goes everywhere
on this channel so don't even worry
about it
but yeah the tactical shovel Sour Patch
Kids ice cream I don't know why people
just really love this and then I just
like there was other sour patch work and
there's the the thing is there's even
more like sour patch stuff that people
have made
there's even more but oh that's right
yeah yeah so Amy got more stuff because
they made even more sour patch kids
stuff and they've made even more now I
don't know if it's worth doing another
video about but there are more and
potentially I could do another video
about the other Sour Patch Kids crap
that they've put out but I only think I
would do one more video this because I
don't think I could tolerate another one
because I just couldn't oh come on oh no
did I oh I'm such an idiot
Oh God Oh Frick okay so but that's fine
that's where am i where am i where was I
here yes okay that's fine that's all
good that's totally fine biak who has
this is starting to lead into the next
big thing that happened in my life but
not necessarily the channels because
there was not many videos coming out
when I was doing this because I was in
Korea I went to Korea for a month in
September I had been promising that I
was gonna go to Korea for a long time
now for like a more sour patch kids
maybe maybe hard maybe on that one you
guys know how flaky I am with videos so
I just hard maybe on that one big big
heart maybe yeah big heart maybe oh god
we've got a lot of members thank you you
will get much girth may you may the
members have bountiful girth and may may
you enjoy your time no seriously I thank
you everybody so much for being a member
I was joking about it before but the
members really are awesome because the
reason I'm able to do some of these
bigger projects like Damien or because
the members fund it that's that's what
it is I put a lot of what the members
pay for their membership back into the
content that I make it's cyclical like
that and that's why I'm more of the mind
of just like super chat why whatever so
thank you to the members and thank you
everybody that is a member of the
channel there are new features coming
out all the time for members and if you
want to become a member we also do
weekly weekly member only live streams
on Mondays or if I'm busy Monday
whenever I can catch up to it they'll
start again this coming Monday in two
days so thank you to the members of the
channel you guys are amazing there's
some rewards that you can get and that's
good thank you there's my pitch and
there's my appreciation for you guys
being awesome but I went to Korea
because for those of you who don't know
I am half Korean on my mother's side if
you seen the video with me and my mom
she is Korean and therefore I am half
Korean the other half is German because
that's what my dad was but oh wait god
stop the presses stop the presses wait
where is it where is it where's it oh
yeah oh yeah oh yeah I forgot that I you
I turned 30 I skipped over my own
birthday I legitimately just skipped my
own birthday
I am very dumb hey this
is a decibel ometer you hear my voice
now that is at this many decibels and
I'm gonna see how loud the things in my
life are alright this is the oh [ __ ]
what did I do excuse me oh [ __ ] it's a
bomb huh ah she's still good so I'm just
gonna put this it's not the cord the
cord ain't long enough it's currently
1:28 its 1:28 I need to go to some place
to get a longer cable so that I can
extend this bad boy okay so I don't know
if i i've ever a little got horrible so
how i don't know if i've ever talked
about this video before i made this
video
literally that that clock is correct it
was 1:28 in the morning on june 28th so
is the morning of it was like june 27th
and then you know calendar turned over
and then it was the 20th so i made this
at this time because i was born on the
28th but i was born very early in the
morning technically if you want to get
technical about it like we could go
hawaii time because I was born in Hawaii
but I didn't I was just like I'm just
gonna go with what the clock says and
that's what it is where I am and that's
what it was and also I was very busy at
the time so I was back home and I was in
Cincinnati and I was a slake and I
screwed I'm just gonna gonna go out and
do this I didn't even know I was gonna
do it I didn't know I was gonna make
this video before I made it it was just
one of those things where I was just
like I wanna I want to spend my birthday
in my own way I've never really cared
about celebrating my birthday I've never
been a presents guy I don't care about
what people get me some people get me
very nice stuff like a me is great about
gifting and I am very poor about gifting
but when it came to my birthday it was
just like I'm gonna do what I like doing
which is making up crap which I bought a
decibel meter a decibel ometer I bought
it
because that sounds like a cool thing to
buy it's like 20 bucks so why not and
then I have that it's somewhere still
but yeah I just went out in the morning
and I was just like very I guess in the
evening late at night and I was just
like I'm I wasn't born until I forget
what the exact time was I say in the
video it is now 5:30 6:00 a.m. I was
born on June 28 1989 at 5:30 6:00 a.m. I
am now officially 30 years old and I
know that's not technically true because
of time zones I was born in Hawaii and
I'm in Cincinnati but this feels right
the Sun is just barely coming up I spent
all night because I wanted to see it I
wanted to be here for it and I wanted to
go into my 30s you know with eyes wide
open kind of like knowing how it's gonna
be because when I went into my 20s I had
no clue who I was or who I wanted to be
I had no idea and I only started this
YouTube thing when I was 22 I was just
about to turn 23 in a few months but I
was 22 and I still had no idea who I was
or what I wanted to be or even if I
liked who I was but the only difference
between those two moments is that when I
was 22 and I served my youtube channel I
wanted to figure out who I was and so
much of my 20s has been defined by
this like doing videos on YouTube making
every day count you know kind of
figuring out who I am
day by day and it hasn't always been
easy like ups and downs you know I I was
thinking thought I was gonna have like
some of this grand wisdom bad look at
this savvy prick can't even is worse
together ya know it's it's really cool I
was very happy that I was able to make
this video and I no idea I was gonna
turn out literally all I was doing was
driving around Cincinnati just killing
time I would make up some [ __ ]
excuse that I have to go there there's
like there's a whole horror movie
subplot I forget what a corner okay car
didn't start up oh yeah getting gas I
forgot like I was I was almost out of
gas and I didn't know I was like I was
totally prepared for my car to run out
of gas I was totally prepared I didn't
know that like I would I would how close
I would get to it
but I was totally prepared because I was
I was in one of those [ __ ] moods you
know you ever get into that point where
you just like I don't I'm just gonna
coast right now whatever happens happens
I will roll with it like weather
lightning strikes me right at this
moment I will handle it just because
like that's the mood I was in I was like
whatever is gonna happen in the next
four hours before I turn 30 is what's
gonna happen and that is exactly what I
did and and that's the attitude that
I've kind of been going into my 30s is
like whatever happens will happen
I'm not coasting I'm doing a lot of
stuff to like affect what I'm doing but
now that I'm six months into my 30s you
know it's still like the same general
feel oh my god wait oh my god it's the
28th I was born June 28th it's not exact
because of days in a month but six
months ago almost exactly I was 30 wow
that's so weird
that's so weird exact we're exactly
halfway through that's so bizarre yeah
anyway yeah that's crazy to think about
anyway sorry
whatever it's 28 big big whup who gives
a [ __ ]
nobody uh so ya know I just I wanted to
approach my 30s with the mindset that I
don't know what it's gonna be I don't
know what I'm gonna do as my defining
thing for the 30s because my 20s were
obviously defined by YouTube and in a
way still my life to this day is defined
by YouTube and I may be my 30s will also
be defined by YouTube but I'm not gonna
let myself become like tunnel vision to
say that I can't do anything else
because I think I've proven at this
point that I can and I'm not the
greatest did everything but you know if
I put my mind to something I'm pretty
good at it and I think that everybody is
that way at some point in their lives so
that's nice yeah that's pretty good
anyway I don't know that sappy [ __ ]
let me grind my old creaky bones over to
another video okay so I'm in Korea right
about now ish man i'ma Dan what a
disappointment oh yeah I'm in Korea
my my my kid cousin here
look at Mike oh wait no sorry look at my
crap haircut this is sale yeah look like
crap haircut that my cousin coming babe
made me good oh you want a civic I could
have punched him I could have well he
would have punched me back for whatever
guy boy look with this haircut and
earbuds in I forget I forget who said it
but apparently someone one of my family
members said looked like I pooped myself
in Korean and I didn't know yeah anyway
yeah so I'm pretty rad I do have air
pods what can I say look YouTube's been
good to me and I've been good to myself
I can't earpods man I am so amazing I'm
so absolutely incredible anyway whatever
guys you already know this about me and
you already know it about yourself but
what's even more interesting is that
while I was in Korea right before I went
to Korea actually I filmed a project I
filmed the project that I didn't think I
was gonna film I had talked about it for
a long time I filmed the drowned man and
let me tell you I am so happy with how
the drowned man turned it is such a fun
video and it was such a fun thing to do
because we filmed it in two days now the
drowned man the drowned man what can I
not say about the drowned man I I put
this out like when I was uh when I was
in Korea and I had other videos come out
in ones Korea but I I did the framework
editing for and then lik see and finish
it off amazingly with this video but god
I'm so
I'm proud of the fact that this video
exists because I didn't think it was
gonna happen I had no time to film it I
was leaving for Korea and I was like man
if I do this I'm not gonna have videos
for all of Korea while I do it
but I did it and I'm so happy that
exists you know I don't even give a [ __ ]
that it doesn't get as many views as say
only 99 iCube people will watch this I
don't care
this video is amazing because of what it
is because it's it's a story a true
story by the way a lot of people doubted
everything in this if you've seen
drowned man if you haven't seen drown
man go watch con man there's three parts
it's amazing but if you have seen drown
man there was a lot of people that were
like that is all made-up [ __ ] no
that's the crazy thing we made fun of it
and we had fun with making it but this
story everything that happened to wait
every word of it is true and verifiable
it is just the most absurd string of
coincidences you've ever seen that's
what makes this story amazing when I
talked for so long about like I'm gonna
make like a documentary series about it
and like wait whoa oh sure yeah when
when you're moving back to Cincinnati
I'll do it I was like yeah yeah but yeah
it happened and it's odds play Barnes
where were you born
Cincinnati Ohio demon spirit poltergeist
whatever it was it all started 2018
sometime late February and it was almost
exactly midnight Molly and I were
pulling into the driveway after 27 hours
of being on airplanes and we were just
so excited to get home and as we pulled
in the driveway and clock struck 12:00
we noticed our front door on the ground
in front of the house lying on the
sidewalk love it love it so much if you
haven't seen it go see it it's such a
fun watch it's three chapters there
about little over 15 minutes peace
they're really well done and what's
basic about it is like it also was nice
for me because it showed that like I
actually kind of knew what the hell I
was doing because we went into it with
no plan there's no script here
everything is just like I had Wade tell
me what the story was we figured out the
beach fort and we were like alright
let's record some [ __ ] let's see what
happens let's have some fun with it and
God it was so fun like that's I think it
was fun to make it was fun to edit it's
fun to put together and it was just an
idea that I wouldn't have done if it
wouldn't exist if I didn't just take the
two days to go to Cincinnati and film it
and then come back and that was really
cool
like I like that and it's hard for me to
get across how much this thing something
like this means for me as a creator of
content to say like this is something
I'm very proud of I am happy this exists
and for you guys to understand the
reasons of why it's hard to get that
across but I'll try to explain it for
you in this way I am a creator of
content I make content creator I make
videos basically long in the short I
tell stories or whatever have you I play
video games and yada yada those are all
very dictionary definition of what I do
but in a sense also what I do is I push
myself to see what I can make like
that's really what I would define myself
as I pushed myself to see how far my
ability to make something has come
versus where I was seven years ago I
could never make this especially in the
timeframe that I can make it what makes
me excited about this idea is that I had
an idea
there was a story I actually [ __ ] did
it which is a big thing like
[ __ ] doing something we executed it
in exactly the way I wanted it to come
out like I had it in my head of how I
wanted to be and turned out that way
number five it like had the amazing
support of the people that I know to
turn it even better lik C and finished
up the editing I knew I could do it and
I did it and that feeling that feeling
by itself to know you can do something
and then you do it is an incredible
feeling and that's the feeling that I'm
trying to get across here I am super
proud of this of drowned man it is not
the best video I've ever made it is not
but it's great and I love it and just
love it great part of 2019 to know that
could happen period to know that could
happen money love it every part of it
some of you understand but some of you
obviously don't so it's all good it's
all good whatever whatever is okay water
one super play it's also so [ __ ] I
love it I love like the stories true but
we make such [ __ ] out of it's so
funny to me I love this love it anyway
alright moving on moving on oh god I
forgot about this video called
destroying my entire ass in 20 seconds
so goddamn funny I love it so much
destroyed such a funny video oh he's not
a funny video it's so stupid but it
exists me and my cousin young BAE
young-bae is awesome by the way that is
so funny this is the video this is the
whole video it's a 21 second video
that's it
I'll pause just like is so funny I the
duality of my channel is no better
Express than the fact that I made I made
the Drowned band which is an actual
three-part documentary like mockumentary
series about my friends leaky house and
then following it up not of not one week
later with destroyed my entire acid 20
seconds like that is so it just I love
that I've got too much power I can do
that Brown mint amazing thing well made
destroying my entire ass choices I love
you too I do I do I really I really love
just [ __ ] around it's so fun anyway
but but but but but in between
sandwiched in between these things is
something that actually is really really
cool this is the [ __ ] promo but
whatever
I made a really cool thing there's some
really cool people yeah really cool
story
it's a scary story you like that right
you like scary stories so why don't you
check the link in the description below
and you can check out the scary story
right now did I made all that people
made it but I check it out link is in
the description
not this week I'm talking about all
right so what what this is referring to
is the edge of sleep the edge of sleep
this right here is the thing how many of
you guys show of hands got got hey
listen hey what are you talking about
listen to me listen to me listen to me
look at me look at look at me why are
you not looking at me what are you doing
you were looking away you're on another
tab you're making food that's not how
this works
pay attention look me in the eyes you're
beautiful
you're off the hook this time so look at
me how many show of hands how many of
Liston sorry take two how many of you
have listened to the edge of sleep right
now show of hands I want to see I want
to see hands hands no yes hands you're
jacking it hey kudos man good on you all
right edge asleep is good all right how
many of you have not put a different
hand up put a completely different in
take the hand that you had before and
then put a different hand up if you have
not seen it because if you have not seen
it if you have not seen it if you have
not listened to it it's so well done
i I did not write there just leave I
want to be very clear about that I did
not write this is one of the things that
I was just hired as an actor in which is
pretty cool
like I I was actually very impressed
there's another thing that was like just
a big brush trying to get it done and it
was in production for a while just
because the audio engineering is
incredible if you go to Apple podcast if
we go to Spotify if you look up the edge
of sleep you will see the full series is
out and you can listen to it all and
it's so amazingly well done the story is
cool I like the story a lot but
I on a technical level of more impressed
by is the audio engineering because I
actually really like audio engineering I
think it's very fun
I like fussing with audio I did the
audio and Damian I liked doing the audio
and like the videos that I do I like it
it's fun but if you have not seen it go
check it out the whole series is
available right now I when it came out I
feel bad because I wasn't able to
dedicate as much time and energy to
promoting it as it probably deserved
like it was like I made a video for it
but this is like a 30-second crap thing
for it and then I've mentioned it a few
more times but the edge asleep is really
like amazingly well done if you have not
seen it or heard it go check it out it's
a story podcast it's wonderful I like it
a lot and I think you will too let me
see if I can find a link for it
dududududu dudududududududu here's your
link is gonna disappear instantly here's
a link to go the Zappa podcast blah blah
blah is gonna unless it sticks to the
top I did it stick I don't know maybe
for you it's stuck I don't know if it's
done
there's also it's also available on
Spotify where you can check it out there
and it's available on various other
podcasting apps so if you have a
podcasting app that you like go check it
out or look for it there called the edge
asleep that came out when it did come
out no I did the thing again that was
September September 24th 2019 so not too
long ago this was not that long ago God
the last portion of this year has been
like so densely packed the last the last
half of this year is like really really
thick really thick okay so pretty soon
here let's go back to let's go back to
looking at the looking at the channel
here okay so I came home from Korea I
did not accomplish my objective of
becoming conversational in Korean
because it's very hard I've been
studying for a while and I hope that a
month
emerging emerging murders emerging
immersing myself in like Korean culture
by living in Seoul would help me and it
did help me incredibly I'm Way better at
Korean now than I was before I left to
go there but I am NOT conversational I
speak in broken Korean I can get my
point across but I can't detail it yeah
but anyway not the point I get back from
Korea and I have so much work to do
because we are leading up to the launch
of a heist with markiplier if there is
one video that defines this year it is a
heist with markiplier there there is no
other video that took as much time in
this year and I say video it's it's a
series it's huge massive like there's no
other project that I dedicated more time
to this year then a heist with
markiplier and so you know I've got you
know various other videos our goose game
came out which is great that electrum of
that I was late to the party but
whatever you know Bigfoot Blair which
finished I liked it more didn't like how
it ended you know
Oh mr. hops a shockingly good horror
game didn't even know that was gonna be
that good there there was some like
quite a few good horror games there I
ate Limburger cheese again which is
great glad to have that the trailer came
out for a heist with markiplier I may be
sailor myself I made this myself
this is gonna change our lives forever
they've gotta be around here somewhere
you're right you know what you're right
but we need to split up cover more
ground that's a great idea
stick to the plan and you'll be just
fine but if you deviate from it for even
a single moment I won't come back for
you okay good luck
[Music]
right in the ice
watch your head
[Music]
or for something so small
love it I love so much I and and like
making this trailer was so fun because
like I I just like making trailers and I
like fussing with sound and I like doing
little music things and I like that sort
of stuff but also just like it was yes
it's so great to make the trailer
because it was like the end stone of the
project for me the videos were all done
for a heist with Mark Clark it was all
done it was already all done
this was decison on the cake to look
back and see what scenes from what
videos I would want to make so that I
could actually bring it to you guys and
release it for free for everybody is
it's just like it was so god it's such a
beautiful moment it wasn't that long ago
but it seems like forever ago now
because so much has happened since then
but at the same time like ah Highsmith
markiplier was the defining moment of
this year for me and I thought I thought
it was going to be that was gonna be it
there's gonna be this and then I could
relax I could kick back and relax but
you guys know that's not the case now
because I guess that's not how I work
but ice with Mark Clark came out oh my
god I love it I know I I'm not even
gonna tell you guys to watch it because
if you haven't seen it by now what are
you even doing with your life like
whatever but it's I really really loved
making it it was so much work but it
turned out so beautifully
anyway it was such like I you guys heard
just now how excited I was that the
drown man came out the way it did
because it was it was a way that I could
show that I could execute on my vision
and I could do what I knew I could do a
heist with mark player is that to an
extreme level like an extreme I didn't
know that I could do it I didn't I had
no idea if I could do that or not and
part of the reason is because we filmed
that back in May
that was before like the drown man for
some of the things that I've been doing
lately and it was just like that
learning experience from working with a
crew of that size and working on a
project of that scope and doing so many
things in a
national setting that I'd never imagined
that I would ever be doing and and being
able to like do it that that alone is
fascinating and it's such a fulfilling
feeling to know that it can happen and
when it finally came out you guys loved
it oh my god you guys loved it and I was
so happy that everyone is loving it and
I I don't care who you like people seem
to think that I am mad at people for
loving like Yancy and stuff I don't give
a [ __ ] I'm just messing with you I don't
care I love that you love it I do
there's no part of me that has any
ill-will towards anyone in my community
ever loving something that I made are
you kidding me of course I love it
because you like something I made that's
phenomenal and god it was such it was
such a fulfilling thing to have it come
out and just be enjoyed the way it was
and like it's out now it's it's so good
it's so good like that's the thing it is
it is inarguably good that's the thing
about it a high school markiplier I've
made a lot of like mediocre content I've
made some decent things I've made some
good things I've made some bad things I
know what when I make something that is
bad or when I make something that is
good but this just to see this is so
much more than what I can make this is
the culmination of the work of many many
dozens of people who worked away at a
vision that I had and they put their all
into it and it turned out incredible
Oh a honey
[Music]
all right we're in you know the plan
right what am I saying
you practically wrote it everything you
need is in your bag so let's synchronize
our watches on three three perfect now
stick to the plan and you'll be just
fine but if you deviate from it for even
a single moment I won't come back for
you okay good luck
what do you think you're doing oh no no
the old steak trick I'm not falling for
that twice yeah I'm gonna look you right
in the eyes nicely done buddy
oh the courting good there's so much
that I could say right now about this
but I already did a livestream
explaining it I'm just enjoyed this is
just for me this is this isn't even for
you guys right now this is for me
planning and speaking a plan looks like
we are
yeah we're moving on to Phase two
you ready on my go go it tracks the
intruder quiet as a ninja suppressing a
fart in church the thing is like when
I'm watching this I remember every
single moment of filming it
I remember the takes that didn't make it
I remember the mistakes we made
I remember everything haze I love seeing
all that come to life great job buddy
I'll meet you over there all right we
are so close to the ball come on stay
low and stay quiet
you want to know my favorite thing about
this bowl to go on you need two keys one
for you one for me all right one two
three security this wasn't in the plans
there are two keys for this vault we
need to get them from those guards or
any guards that are moderately less
competent than those why don't you go
back the way we came and why don't I
have a little bit of a chat with that
guard over there
be back in a flash
the thing is like if I could do this
over again the thing that I would change
is making everything move faster that
was like my objective through the whole
shoot was just making everything faster
but the problem with condense timelines
is it's hard to plan out something to
get it to his speed you have to do
things unlike the third or fourth take
you can't do 20 takes on everything or
else you wouldn't ever have time that's
the only nitpick thing I would say about
this be back in a flash
oh you gotta like I want to come on I
think these are what we need to get in
that vault oh this is it you ready now
on three one oh this is really it
this is what we've been working towards
all those years it's finally ours this
is gonna change our lives forever it's
fine this is why we plan oh okay I see
two ways out of here
there just so happens to be a sewer that
runs directly beneath this vault I
suppose we could have gone in that way
but that doesn't matter we could either
go through the sewer all sneaky-like or
we could go out Joran is blazing yeah I
found these bad boys in the pirate
exhibit on the way over here but we got
to choose fast I think they're on the
way they're not gonna be friendly when
we're in deal with the box okay so uh
we're not gonna go through the whole
thing we're not gonna go through the
whole thing and we're not gonna go
through the whole thing but what we are
gonna go through is two things in
particular I gotta go to this one very
wonderful wonderful wonderful wonderful
work of art that was orchestrated by the
lovely and beautiful schmoyoho I'll let
it speak for itself it's something that
we've been really missing here lately
now I need you to respect me and help me
and my friend break
to break out of this place
why would anyone wanna break out the
outside world recoils in fear thinking
of a slip-up they'll get locked up in
need you killing yourself just Americans
while I'm working on my tail and kicking
on my feet you can't be living in prison
there's always something to do
and you know who's payin everyone to
everyday awake
Robin for
[Music]
and every single one of us the maxim
we
[Music]
we pray my god
but in me rhyme who's what
[Music]
I don't wanna be free not the life of me
now
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm just praying
so tell me Iowa anyway I just need to
get that out of my system because it's
this is something special I really like
that and all the love in the world needs
to be sent to Schmo Yoho and the lovely
people this is two of them back here
andrew is two of them they are awesome
they put so much work into this and they
made this song something special but and
and like I said we're not gonna go
through everything but what we are gonna
go through is a few select things and
apparently there was there was one one
there was something that was an
injustice on injustice a horrible
injustice on my part in the explanation
livestream that I didn't get to and
honestly it wasn't intentional I forgot
I forgot that we didn't go to it I
really did and also part of me was also
probably like at the time I didn't do it
in the beginning because I was like some
people need to see for themselves but at
this point I don't care we're gonna go
to a deep dark place a very deep place
so spooky so deep so dark Oh so spooky
so spooky we're gonna go somewhere real
spooky okay all right look at that face
spooky okay all right okay this is gonna
be great and don't you worry about a
thing
because our watches are still
synchronized which means that we're
gonna be back up here in exactly five
minutes no matter what happens so you go
down that tunnel I'll go down this
tunnel and if you see anything
thing out of the ordinary you just
turned that sweet little took us around
[Music]
always spinning his yarns his webs
he's Lord I always thought that you were
traveling - games perpetually plundered
a depositor helpless lost perhaps I the
crazy one perhaps you've meant a hundred
times orbit you simply don't remember it
grass you're tired meeting myself over
over and over
then you just miss my pretty face it
doesn't matter people like you only want
one thing and it's disgusting you want
answers well games were always his forte
but along it is one moment of
self-indulgence so much trouble or for
something so small do you really want to
know what's inside this box the truth
the lies he's told I know how much you
bother crew the games throughout this
heist I find them all
you'll get your truth but that's all
cool cool
there it is that's that's what we didn't
watch during the stream I think I talked
about it I'm pretty sure I talked about
it during the stream but yeah so that is
the the darker Blair bath I didn't think
I was gonna put one in this to be
perfectly honest like I was like I only
wanted it in there just to satisfy
people's needs to have him in there
people would be like woody got it you
didn't the other one and yeah he wasn't
the other one so I was like yeah put him
in there he'll be he'll be the puzzle
master but everyone was always thinking
like there was something more to it and
there's like there's nothing more if you
couldn't tell by this pose a bit of a
joke and then obviously the code was
called out right here for people that
couldn't find the code it's right there
and there was mistakes with the code
because the font was bad because there
was capitals and not capitals and then
it was a nightmare but it was just to
the websites to get some
behind-the-scenes stuff and that way you
get to the bloopers and whatnot and
that's some pretty good stuff anyway
that's that we didn't see it in this one
but we are not done with this year just
yet we're not doing with this year oddly
enough no the year didn't just end when
I made that not two weeks later actually
exactly two weeks later well before that
I did that there was a problem with
YouTube and then there was but that got
fixed so that's good but not two weeks
later unas honest I had the idea for who
nasaan is before a heist came out and I
can't [ __ ] believe we committed to
this but we did it and it's been amazing
so far and I've been super happy with it
you guys know we're doing this honest is
right good you better when it's honest
is mean anything we made a new channel
and it's been so unbelievably fun if you
don't know actually this is this was a
posted November 15th November 15th but
this video was also posted 15th at
exactly 12:00 1:00
apparently there needs to be an ad no no
no what but uh-oh
full 15-second ad Oh God une asan it's
breaking in that ad money oh yeah let me
let me just let this one play once we
live our lives taking each second for
granted but what would you do if you
knew how much time you have left onus on
us one year this channel much like all
of you has a limited amount of time and
every day we march ever closer to this
channels inevitable doom that means
we'll be uploading every single day
until the clock strikes zero and then
it's game over
bye-bye finito finished curtains gone
gone night-night dead forever make no
mistake this doesn't mean that we'll
just stopped uploading went on runs out
we will be deleting this channel and
every single video on it and you'll
never be able to see them again because
much like death you can't take it with
you and all we'll have is the memories
that we make along the way and merch so
the clock starts now
but the choice is yours will you join us
Oh will you miss out on your one chance
to be a part of illness honest because
time is already running out this train
is already moving so subscribe now
because death is coming ask Not For Whom
the Bell Tolls ring the bell for thyself
to know for there are no second chances
and if you miss out all you'll be left
with is regret memento mori
we'll see you tomorrow
this artists yeah that's uh neon II uh
if you haven't checked out earnest
honest we've been putting out that he's
got five million bees alright that's
crazy
we've been putting out some just just
banger content ever since this moment I
have been uploading on my channel and
then I've been uploading honest honest
and let me tell you through new songs
videos are much harder to make but God
are they more fun not that making videos
like for my channel is not fun but you
know I'm talking about gaming content
versus whatever the hell you call the
content we're doing here it is
delightful but the point that was made
in that video is true in one year from
that moment we will be deleting when
it's honest it will be gone and we will
not be reloading anything anywhere the
point of it is to showcase the temporary
nature of what we do here in life the
internet may seem like a permanent place
but at the same time we choose what we
do with our time we have and that's
what's on us is all about and we choose
to do some really stupid things oh my
god that's at 4.1 million views of god
some of these these videos almost all of
them bangers I love every video that
we've made here is so much fun
so like god it's just so there's some
excellent content here oh yeah sorry
about content like bleeding content out
I I have been living for this moment I
can funnel my content blood into this
channel and god there's some good
content here oh there's some good kind
yeah but it will be deleted it
absolutely will be so if you haven't
checked it out now's the time because we
announced this a month
ago it has been a month and a half
already gone like that and in 10 1/2
more months this channel will no longer
exist your ability to subscribe to this
channel will no longer exist
your ability to ring the bell
to be notified to comment to like on any
video here will be removed in 10 and a
half months and that is a beautiful
thing and god there's been some good
content here there's been some good good
cooking with sex toys beautiful video
amazing video purging our sins with a
netipot I love it hotdogs to death
what a nightmare of a video to see
making your own sensory deprivation tank
was just some sublime sublime the good
kind of got back the bad guy wake up
like the worst kind of cupping Ethan got
kick to the balls oh my god oh we waxed
each other's pubes ah yeah healing
therapy AI predicted and we're gonna die
watching him like so many memories the
thing is like I can go back to like you
saw how I was like oh yeah one to skip a
few ninety-nine a hundred like with with
this honest every single video is worth
a watch that's the beauty of it is every
single video is worth watching and yet
even though there's this delightful
content here it's delightful there's
content here and it is it's it's like a
car crash you can't look away that's the
thing but if you do look away you'll
miss out so give it it give it a look I
put a link in the description of this
this stream here if you want to check it
out it's right down there Oona's honest
go check it out while you still can
because someday you won't be able to
yeah we did nude paintings oh the barrel
ease in destroying the barrel we gave
away are we got a million a million gold
play button we gave it away because you
can't take it with you so we just
we're committed to kind of giving away
everything here it's very temporary so
cool I can talk for hours about this oh
yeah in today's video is a it's an
interesting one oh yeah uh this is not
porn by the way all right why blanket
sweep this is not porn that's not this
is not porn it's not just saying that
right now definitely not anything weird
drank each other's pee that's fine
totally fine yep absolutely please
explain the barrel the barrel is gone
you what the barrel is gone I'm gonna
wash it the barrel is gone if you want
to see it you can see for yourself the
barrel is gone baby bears gone bears
gone girls gone anyway
so that is November 15th which is right
here
from then on playing puck G V are a
little more more five nights at Freddy's
stuff five nights at Freddy's special
delivery came out trying to look at this
and then one on Christmas break there
are other things that happened obviously
it's very easy to look at say all these
videos Hey look I'm streaming it's very
easy to look at this video and just like
count the days as an outside observer
but for me it's it's like very different
every day was working towards making
videos for you that's that's my life
that's it that's all I do
that's all I want to do it's how I've
sat on my life at the expense of a lot
of things that is really what I do and
that was my twenty nineteen that leads
me to this point here where we are just
a couple days away from a new decade and
just like with me turning 30 I don't
know what 2020 is going to be defined by
not for you I don't know what its gonna
be defined by for me I don't know what
the 20s as a whole is gonna be defined
by I really don't know there's so much
like out there that that is just like
open for potential you know what I mean
the future is unknown and that's kind of
the nice thing about doing as honest is
it keeps my perspective on just what is
important what are we doing like how am
I gonna spend the time that I have
while that channel exists like are we're
gonna commit to getting videos out every
day because the clock just won't stop
ticking and for me personally like with
2019 being done and accomplishing all
this stuff like I want to keep rolling
into 2020 I'm gonna be very busy but at
the same time I'm gonna be very happy
because I get to do what I like I get to
do what I love and I know that's a rare
thing I understand that and I appreciate
that it is an extremely rare thing to be
able to do what you love and I get to do
it it's it's it's something I never want
to take for granted it's something that
I never want to waste it's something
that I want to take advantage of while I
have the time to take advantage of it
like I don't know how long I'm gonna
live I really don't and I know it's a
little early to be thinking about death
but you know I still think about it I
don't know how much time I have I don't
know how much time any of us have so I
got to spend the time that I have making
what I want to make so that I don't
waste any of it so I can't look back on
my life and have regrets for it and
that's just a personal philosophy of
mine and it's something that really
carried me through 2019 and out of like
a very depressed you know part of 2018
was still me coming out of a real low
funk 2017 was a was real down a year and
2018 was still plagued by it between 19
imade like if I could put my entire 20
19 in a few words it would be I made
[ __ ] I made [ __ ] happen I made things
move I did
that would be it I did things yeah well
they were good as questionable but I
made some pretty incredible stuff and I
made the most of my 2019 I can I can say
that with confidence I did not waste a
moment of 2019 I took advantage of every
single opportunity that was in front of
me I put I paved the road for me to move
forward with other cool things that I'm
doing and I took advantage of 2019 and I
want you guys to know that if you can't
say the same thing that is okay that is
completely okay
that is 100% absolutely okay if 2019 was
not a great year for you and it's no
guarantee that 2020 will be a great for
your year for you either because it's no
great no guarantee that 2020 will be a
great year for me I'm gonna work hard
but it doesn't mean that it's going to
be wonderful the point is to always keep
moving forward no matter what always
keep trying because even when I was in
my lowest point even when I was really
like feeling pessimistic about making
content making videos making YouTube
stuff and doing the things outside of
YouTube like acting or or directing or
whatever I was doing like and just go
with confidence if it's something that
you want to do do it to the best of your
ability don't waste a moment wallowing
in whether or not it's the right thing
to do or whether not you're happy with
it you know like definitely consider
that but if you've got something that
you see as a goal for yourself then go
chase it
like I wouldn't let anything get in the
way of what I'm doing because it's so
important to me and I work the rest of
my life around it and I do make time for
things that are also important in my
life I'm not saying that making content
is the only important thing in my life
but you know just move forward with
confidence and I think that's all that
matters anyway thank you everybody so
much for watching this longer than I
expected stream about 2019 it's been
quite a year it's been a lot of really
cool things and I know I'm probably
forgetting some stuff am I forgetting
some stuff guys in chat right now let me
if I'm forgetting some things let me
know if I'm forgetting some things what
am I forgetting
yeah yeah I know I'm great whatever too
much chatting looks like I have not oh
yeah well that's not my charity I was on
game theorists Jerry but that's not
maturity I I would like to in 2020 work
with more people that would be nice
I would like definitely to work with
more people west of loathing whatever
that was just some DLC that came out
cloak yeah cloak happened those more
mourn cloak I talked about the podcast
the edge asleep okay whatever I guess we
got everything if I forgot anything may
I be struck down may I be struck down as
I stand here today so moral this story
guys here comes the moral hey get away
from making out with whoever you were
making out with stop it look at me look
at me look at me in my eyes look at me I
mean all the things that we discussed
here that you need to check out from the
wisdom tooth removal to add your sleep
to Damien to the drowned man to
Highsmith markiplier to onus on us to
all the other stuff that I've done that
has happened in 2019 go check it out
all you need to do good my channel go to
the videos tab look back at past year
and enjoy because there's some cool
stuff out there and if you've missed
some of it go check it out or all be in
your closet tonight with a knife and an
accent I don't know which one I'm gonna
use so you better watch me the night is
still young
even if you're in the UK nice still
young can get a lot done don't waste a
minute sticky so check it out ok cool
anyway thank you take care of yourselves
take care of each other
subscribe if you want to ring the bell
if you don't like it if you can if
you're able to I don't know if you can I
don't know if you I don't I don't know
if you're tough enough to like this
video I don't know I don't know if
you're a high enough level to even come
close to subscribing to my channel you
have to be a certain threshold of idiot
to even approach me and this channel to
get to this content you got a gonna be
your IQ has to be under this bar you
have to be this or below only 99 IQ
individuals you have to be exactly 99 IQ
no more no less to be subscribed if
you're above go Widow a if you're below
get out of here
don't eat you get out of it right there
99 that's what you got to be right there
so anyway thank you everybody so much
for watching check out the videos that I
mentioned here and thank you for a great
2019 and I look forward to seeing what
the hell I'm gonna be up to in 2020
because you may not know but also I
don't know I never know what the hell
I'm doing
it's amazing that anything gets done but
sometimes gets done well and it makes
something cool so thanks again I'm a
gadiot and as always I'll see you in the
next video bye